- AW, LOOK AT MY LITTLE CUBS
OF ANARCHY.
ARE YOU EXCITED
ABOUT YOUR NEW BIKE?
- YES.
- HERE YOU GO, BUDDY.
- WHAT THE [bleep] IS THAT?
I ASKED FOR A MOTORCYCLE.
- MALLOY, WE BOTH KNOW
YOU'RE NOT BIG ENOUGH.
BESIDES, THIS IS JUST AS COOL.
- I'M A BIG BOY.
I'M A BIG BOY.
- I AM NOT
GETTING ON THAT THING.
- NOT WITHOUT YOUR SAFETY GEAR.
- I LOOK RIDICULOUS.
EVERYBODY'S GONNA LAUGH AT ME.
- MALLOY, NO ONE'S GONNA
LAUGH AT YOU.
[laughter]
- THAT'S IT.
I'M GONNA GO
SET UP THE KILL ROOM.
- DON'T FORGET
YOUR OUTSIDE HELMET.
DADDY'S GOTTA PROTECT
HIS LITTLE THERAPY PET.
[all gasp]
- YOU'RE ALIVE?
- YES. WHY?
- OH, WHEN YOU WERE TWO HOURS
LATE, WE ASSUMED YOU WERE DEAD.
- WE EVEN WROTE YOUR OBITUARY.
- "STEVE WILLIAMS.
LIVED, DIED, FAT."
THAT'S IT?
WHY DIDN'T YOU LIST
ANY OF MY ACCOMPLISHMENTS?
- UH, WE SAID FAT.
- HOW ABOUT THE FACT THAT
I'VE BEEN RANGER OF THE MONTH
FOR YEARS?
- STEVE, IT'S ABOUT TIME
WE TOLD YOU.
THAT AWARD IS MEANINGLESS.
YOUR MEDAL IS
A SNAPPLE CAP WE PAINTED GOLD.
- OH, MY GOD.
I HAVEN'T DONE ANYTHING
WITH MY LIFE.
WHEN I'M DEAD,
NO ONE WILL REMEMBER ME.
- NOBODY GIVES A SHIT, STEVE.
I'M OUT OF HERE.
- DON'T FORGET
YOUR BUBBLE ARMOR.
- I CAN'T BREATHE!
- [chuckles]
HAVE FUN, LITTLE BUDDY.
STAY IN THE DRIVEWAY.
[crash]